aquaman andromeda tells the story of a  crew been sent in to investigate a  unidentified  object we're also telling the story in a  way where aquaman is entirely new and  rediscoverable  [Music]  in course of this they they encountered  the creature that landed into the ocean  but they also  have first contact with aquaman for me  the ocean is an incredibly terrifying  place and of course  aquaman exists within that everyone  wants a piece of this thing so black  manta gets involved  i opened that double paid spread of  aquaman fighting the crack and anyone  who looks at that is gonna go yeah this  in itself is is worth  the the price of entry  you've got your big bombastic  big action sequences but it's also a  book of very quiet moments being in the  ocean underwater  uh accounts for a lot of pressure  and and the things we tried to drown in  our past begin to resurface  [Music]  you